edmonds und einer anschließenden
pressekonferenz herzlich willkommen zum
zdf spezial zum abschluss dieses g7
treffens sobald das statement beginnt
schalten wir uns direkt zu bis dahin
wollen wir schon mal eine erste
einordnung vornehmen und zwar beginnend
mit theo koll neben leiter unseres
zdf-hauptstadtstudios theo wird dieser
gipfel denn am ende ein erfolg gewesen
sein für den gastgeber kann man das so
pauschal bewerten kann man es jetzt
schon bewährten
wir sollten dass sie abwarten was der
kanzler genau sagt aber ich würde ein ja
aber als erfolg
bescheinigen es ist so es gibt natürlich
die eher klassischen g7 beschlüsse man
wird viereinhalb milliarden dollar
bereitstellen gegen die hungerkrise das
zählt eher in die kategorie dessen was
man von den g7 erwartet denn das
zehnfache wird ungefähr gebraucht nach
aussagen der un das aber ist es gibt
nichts konkretes zu den häfen in der
ukraine man hat sich bemüht da eine
lösung zu finden oder vorzuschlagen wie
man diese häfen öffnen kann da gibt es
nur absichtserklärungen
das gute aber ist dass man hier gäste
dazu geladen hat und das ist eine 1
öffnung in einem prozess einer neuen
weltordnung natürlich konnte man nicht
erwarten dass hier die fünf gäste dazu
geladen worden sind sich jetzt sofort
auf seite der g7 schlagen und mit mit
den g7 im grunde in die zukunft gehen
aber es ist ein prozess begonnen worden
und das ist ganz wichtig wir sprechen
die gastländer an man sah da gestern
sehr harmonische bilder man will diese
länder ja eben enger an sich binden auch
mit blick auf russland aber wenn man
diesen zuckerguss dieser schönen bilder
mal weg kratzt ist man denn da in der
substanz wirklich weitergekommen also
mit indien soll es innerhalb eines
jahres eine art partnervertrag geben wie
gesagt es ist der beginn eines langen
prozesses man kommt da sehr spät die g7
sind im grunde weit hinter china china
und auch russland haben sich natürlich
um diese länder bemüht der westen hat in
vielen bereichen der welt ja auch keinen
guten ruf sei es aus kolonialer
vergangenheit oder aus dem zeitgeschehen
der letzten jahre und jahrzehnte
es ist aber wichtig sich um diese länder
zu kümmern die haben alle natürlich
unterschiedliche perspektiven wie der
kanzler sagte gestern und
unterschiedliche interessen auch also
wenn man sich mal beispielsweise senegal
anschaut dort hat als scholz vor ort war
man ihm gesagt ja aber sind doch eure
sanktionen des westens
den hunger hier auslösen denn hier seid
daran schuld dass das getreide nicht
exportiert werden kann der umstand dass
russland den krieg angefangen hat und
die häfen blockiert war in der
perspektive des seliger nicht vorhanden
oder bei indien ist es so natürlich
braucht indien die usa auch gegen den
starken nachbar china aber sie haben ein
enges verhältnis zu russland drei
viertel der der indischen waffen kommen
aus sowjetischen beständen kommen aus
russland und sie profitieren jetzt von
dem öl das sie verstärkt aus russland
bekommen und auch der kohle die übrigens
noch mit einem rabatt versehen ist und
da muss man einfach auch der
wirklichkeit ins auge blicken das wollen
wir tun in den nächsten minuten in
dieser stunde theo vielen dank bis
hierher heute morgen gab es im schloss
elmau die letzte von insgesamt sieben
arbeitssitzungen in diesen minuten nun
so war es vorgesehen verabschieden sich
die gipfelteilnehmer voneinander
vorübergehend die meisten werden sich
heute nachmittag gleich wieder sehen in
madrid beim nato-gipfel dort cornelia
donath nun erst einmal mit einem blick
auf diesen letzten gipfel vormittag und
mit einer ersten kurzen bilanz am morgen
kommen sie noch einmal zusammen in
kleiner runde zufrieden mit gesprächen
und ersten ergebnissen die g7 chefs
haben sich darauf geeinigt an einem
möglichen preis deckel für russisches öl
und gas zu arbeiten russland soll
gezwungen werden öl deutlich günstiger
an großabnehmer wie etwa indien zu
verkaufen
außerdem haben sie sich dazu
verpflichtet knapp fünf milliarden
dollar im kampf gegen den hunger
bereitzustellen und sie stellen sich
hinter die idee von kanzler scholz für
einen internationalen klima club der
unter anderem die treibhausgase
reduzieren und bis ende des jahres an
den start gehen soll außerdem produkte
die mit zwangsarbeit hergestellt wurden
sollen von den globalen lieferketten
ausgeschlossen wäre
aber vor allem ging es in ellmau darum
zeichen zu setzen gegen einen der nicht
da war putin und dem ukrainischen
präsidenten selensky zu zeigen wir
stehen an deiner seite mit dem angriff
gestern auf das einkaufszentrum in
krementschouk eskaliert der russische
staatschef den krieg in der ukraine
weiter am abend veröffentlichen die g7
chefs ein statement in dem sie den
angriff scharf verurteilen der russische
präsident putin und die verantwortlichen
werden dafür rechenschaft ablegen müssen
es gibt weiter finanzielle humanitäre
sowie militärische hilfe für die ukraine
so lange es nötig ist wir werden nicht
ruhen ehe russland seinen grausamen und
sinnlosen krieg gegen die ukraine
beendet zum abschluss des gipfels geht
es noch mal vor allem um die neuordnung
der welt die sich im zeichen des ukraine
krieges gerade neu sortiert die
demokratien in aller welt sollen
gestärkt werden
us-präsident beiden reiste wegen
schlechten wetters schon früher ab als
geplant direkt zum nächsten mammut
treffen dem nato gipfel in madrid
ja viele themen viele krisen die hier
diskutiert worden wir wollen das
einordnen wir wollen sortieren theo
zunächst die ukraine das alles
überragende thema wir haben gehört
gestern gab es dann die erklärung man
werde die ukraine unterstützen und zwar
so lange wie nötig das erinnerte sehr an
die formulierung draghis whatever it
takes damals zur beruhigung der
finanzmärkte
jetzt ist es zur beruhigung der ukraine
gedacht auch als signal an russland wird
es denn endlich wirkungsvoll sein können
wie damals
also ich glaube das ist ein starkes
signal es wird sicherlich auch jetzt auf
dem nächsten gipfel zu dem ja die ersten
schon abgereist sind wie joe biden auf
dem nato gipfel wird es dazu auch noch
weiteres geben das drückt sich ja häufig
in waffenlieferungen aus die jetzt auch
verstärkt kommen aber es ist ein klares
politisches signal und ich kam eben
gerade die eilmeldung dass man sich auch
mit für eine konferenz für den
wiederaufbau engagieren will auch das
ist das klare signal dass man an der
seite der ukraine steht und auch bleibt
ja schauen wir noch mal auf die
konkreten zusagen finanziell gab es die
ja 28 milliarden euro wurden da fest
zugesagt bei den waffenlieferungen sogar
schon angesprochen daher ist es
allerdings etwas weniger konkret wir
werden weiter versuchen koordinieren die
dringenden bedürfnisse der ukraine für
militärische und defensive ausrüstung zu
erfüllen das war jetzt nicht sehr
konkret oder nein das wird natürlich am
ende dann auch individuell in den
einzelnen staaten entschieden das g7
format ist ja ein sehr informelles es
ist ja keine grunde offizielle
institution in dem sinne dass man da
solche beschlüsse fassen uns wird jeder
staat für sich entscheiden und dann
entsprechende liefern wenn es gerade im
beitrag gesehen die reaktion der g7 auch
auf den angriff auf das einkaufszentrum
in krementschouk gestern darin heißt es
das sei ein weiteres kriegsverbrechen
und der russische präsident putin und
die verantwortlichen werden dafür zur
rechenschaft gezogen wenn dafür
rechenschaft ablegen müssen wenn wir
jetzt mal voraus blicken auf den
g20-gipfel in indonesien im november
putin ja tatsächlich auch hinkommen will
wenn man da zum beispiel auf den
gastgeber schaut indonesien
staatspräsident der ja auch hier zu gast
war da hat man nicht so sehr den
eindruck dass putin dort wirklich zur
verantwortung gezogen würde oder
zumindest ist er eingeladen und das
stellt natürlich die hier vorhandenen g7
auch vor die frage reist man denn hin
und trifft dort booten wird es
interessant sein was im communiqué sich
da finden kann und wird zwei stimmen
dazu gab es ja schon ursula von der
leyen hat klar gesagt wir lassen uns das
format g20 nicht dadurch nehmen dass
putin kommt sondern er muss sich dann
unseren kritischen fragen und
kommentaren aufstellen und olaf scholz
hat gestern auch gesagt der lässt das
noch offen und entscheidet erst kurz vor
dem g 20 aber das klang auch er nach
einer geplanten teilnahme apropos
kritische fragen die pressekonferenz hat
nach wie vor nicht begonnen vielen dank
theo erneut das gibt uns nun gelegenheit
die perspektive noch ein wenig zu weit
uns die us perspektive auf das ganze
einzuholen von unserem washington
korrespondenten mrt wissen emma
präsident joe biden steht gerade zu
hause ja ziemlich unter druck im
november sind die wichtigen
kongresswahlen
vorab hieß es daher muss was mit nach
hause bringen von diesem gipfel wird er
das also er glaubt es jedenfalls selber
er hat vorab bevor die
abschlusserklärung jetzt gleich
irgendwann veröffentlicht wird schon
selber eine erklärung ohne staffel ist
raus gegeben und darin feiert er doch
eine ganze reihe von punkten und allen
voran im grunde genommen dass der rest
der welt die g7 aber auch die
schwellenländer ein stück weit das
narrativ unterstützen was er seit über
einem jahr verbreitet nämlich dass man
sich in einer großen auseinandersetzung
zwischen demokratie und autoritarismus
befindet der ukraine krieg ist
gewissermaßen der beweis dafür und dass
die schwellenländer hier mit am tisch
gesessen haben ist tatsächlich ich sag
mal eine zeiten werden die ebenfalls
jedenfalls aus der sicht der usa weil
sie glauben das sind länder die hier
dabei waren auf einladung deutschlands
die tatsächlich eher zu den demokratien
zählen als multiplikatoren dienen können
und mit denen hat man einiges vereinbart
sei eine enge partnerschaft im kampf
gegen den klimawandel mit ganz konkreten
punkten infrastrukturprojekte in
schwellen und entwicklungsländern in der
welt und diese länder haben auch die
erklärung zur demokratie und zur
verteidigung der demokratie mit
unterzeichnet und das ist ein ganz
wichtiges signal aus sicht des weißen
hauses weil man die sorge hat dass die
autoritären regime russland und china
weiter in den nächsten jahren druck
machen werden dass wir nicht überraschen
dass das weiße haus dass joe biden hier
auf die erfolge hinweist so wie er sie
zumindest interpretiert wenn wir aber
mal auf eine andere konkrete maßnahme
schauen den ölpreis tracker den er ja
unbedingt heute von dem es auch hieß
zwischenzeit nicht da werde es wohl eine
einigung geben ihren elmau heute morgen
nun hieß es man prüfe weiter das klingt
jetzt nicht nach großen fortschritt ja
da sagen die amerikaner der teufel
steckt im detail und man muss im grunde
genau überlegen wie der mechanismus dann
ist wie stellt man sicher dass dann eben
ein niedrigerer ölpreis für alle
garantiert ist und dass es keine
sonderrabatte gibt oder einander stelle
wieder mehr geld gefordert wird und das
ist nicht einfach der auftrag ist
dennoch klar und er wird auch in der
abschlusserklärung stehen man will dass
man will diese ölpreis bremse und wir
hören aus den delegationen dass auch die
schwellenländer an so etwas interesse
haben weil natürlich auch sie probleme
haben mit steigenden energiepreisen und
gleichzeitig auch das und wichtiges
signal hat man sich ja verständlich mit
den schwellenländern dass man massiv den
umstieg auf erneuerbare technologien
umstellen will energien umstellen will
und dafür auch wieder große
investitionen anbietet und eben auch
einen austausch von technologie- dann
schauen wir noch mal kurz zurück
interessant war eine szene gleich zu
beginn des gipfels vorgestern da hat joe
biden den bundeskanzler so ein bisschen
getätschelt und ihm überschwänglich
gedankt für sein engagement mit blick
auf die ukraine für seine führungsrolle
in europa lange hat man dazu aus
washington ja so ziemlich genau das
gegenteil gehört war das lob ihr jetzt
war das echt oder war das ein
großzügiges großzügiges geschenk ich
glaube es war einerseits echt weil man
ist dankbar dass deutschland in worten
und jetzt auch zunehmend den taten die
zeitenwende vorantreibt aber es hat
natürlich zwei gründe dass eine man
hofft dass deutschland eine
führungsrolle in europa auch weiterhin
übernimmt und zwar weit über ukraine und
über den konflikt mit russland hinaus
weil es geht eben um das große ganze
demokratien gegen autoritär ismus und
die amerikaner sehen als die große ja
sie sagen sogar bedrohung der zukunft
den autoritarismus chinas da wird auch
die abschlusserklärung gleich sehr klare
worte beinhalten sagt jedenfalls das
weiße haus wird bei der nato der fall
sein und da muss man deutschland
überzeugen dass es bereit ist eben trotz
wirtschaftlicher verbindungen mit china
sich gemeinsam an die seite der anderen
zu stellen und das zweite ist natürlich
hat man den usa sorge um die demokratie
im eigenen land und die große frage ist
wer wird im jahr 2024 zum präsidenten
gewählt und da ist es auch wichtig dass
hier weichen gestellt werden mit einem
stark in deutschland in europa was diese
rolle das voranzutreiben in diesem kampf
gegen den autoritarismus mit übernehmen
kann wer 2024 us präsident wird alter
oder womöglich neuer oder vermutlich
auch alter das ist ein gedanke den ihr
sicher viele mit gedacht haben in den
letzten tagen vielen dank an dieser
stelle wir richten den blick jetzt nach
vorn die gehört nach dem gipfel ist vor
dem gipfel für alle g7 staats und
regierungschefs bis auf den japanischen
heißt es nun von ellmau weiter reisen
nach madrid wo heute nachmittag dann der
nato gipfel beginnt und auch der hat
durch die veränderte weltlage natürlich
eine ganz andere bedeutung gewonnen als
als vergangene gipfel dieser art natalie
wollmann berichtet
höchste sicherheitsvorkehrungen am
konferenzzentrum in madrid wo morgen der
nato gipfel beginnt schon im vorfeld gab
es aus dem nato-hauptquartier ein klares
signal richtung moskau
wir werden die nato eingreiftruppe
umgestalten und die zahl dieser
schnellen eingreifkräfte über 300.000
erhöhen wie fandet tauschen bislang sind
40.000 soldatinnen und soldaten in
dieser truppe nun sollen es fast achtmal
mehr werden die nato wird damit deutlich
schlagkräftiger doch streit droht bei
der frage der nord erweiterung der
türkische präsident erdogan blockiert
weiterhin die aufnahme schwedens und
finnlands er behauptet sie würden
kurdischen terroristen schutz gewähren
was beide länder zurückweisen sowie
dennis nordschweden ist und wird kein
sicherer hafen für terrorismus seien die
zuständigen behörden arbeiten intensiv
daran gefährdende personen auszuweisen
schweden hofft nun auf konstruktive
gespräche die aufnahme in die nato hatte
es zusammen mit finnland bereits mitte
mai beantragt doch die entscheidung über
neue mitglieder muss einstimmig fallen
und erdogan lenkt nicht
einlösen hopp auf dem gipfel werden wir
unseren gesprächspartnern diese
heuchelei mit den terroristischen
organisationen wie der pkk und
dokumenten informationen und bildern
belegen
dass terrorismus argument kommt dem
türkischen präsidenten vor den kommen
der neuwahlen in der türkei vermutlich
sehr recht
zu beginn des krieges kann man wirklich
sagen dass die mehrzahl der türken
geglaubt hat dass dieser krieg von der
nato provoziert worden ist vor diesem
hintergrund deutlich dass erdogan mit
seiner blockade großen
gesellschaftlichen rückhalt hat und da
stimmen gewinnen kann der nato
generalsekretär wird nun versuchen
müssen zu vermitteln der streit soll
nicht den gipfel überschattet
stattdessen soll hier ein neues
strategisches konzept beschlossen werden
dass russland als größte bedrohung
benennt
bevor wir genau das gleich vertiefen
werfen wir mal kurz einen blick auf die
szenerie vor dem schloss elmau die
pressekonferenz nach wie vor nicht
begonnen die reihen in den journalisten
stellen die fühlen sich allmählich aber
noch kein signal gehört dass es da
tatsächlich in den nächsten minuten
losgeht haben das natürlich weiter im
blick und nutzen die zeit um wie gesagt
das thema nato zu vertiefen mit unserer
brüssel korrespondentin in brüssel ist
ja nicht nur die eu beheimatet sondern
auch die nato hat dort ihr hauptquartier
an dieses neue strategische konzept von
dem da gerade im beitrag die rede war
lässt sich schon erkennen wie das im
kern aussehen wird ja die nato
botschafter die sozusagen die operativen
verhandlungen führen die haben das
letzte wochenende verhandelt gehören an
manche morgen will bis vier uhr morgens
und haben an jedem wort gefällt dieses
strategische konzept soll ja sozusagen
eine art beschreibung der weltlage aus
militärischer und nato sicht sein und
das wird so ungefähr alle zehn bis zwölf
jahre verabschiedet das alte ist jetzt
zwölf jahre alt und damals sah man
russland noch als strategischen partner
das hat sich natürlich seit der krim
annexion und besonders seit dem krieg in
der ukraine stark verändert in dem neuen
strategischen konzept heißt es jetzt
russland sei eine direkte und
unmittelbare bedrohung das ist neu und
außerdem wird in dem strategischen
konzept auch um die formulierungen zur
china gerungen china kam im alten
strategischen konzept überhaupt nicht
vor wird jetzt erwähnt als bedrohung als
herausforderung dar über das wird sehr
spannend sein wie das formuliert wird
wir hören dass die deutsche delegation
versucht hat die formulierungen nicht zu
hart ausfallen zu lassen bundeskanzler
scholz setzt da die linie seiner
vorgängerin fort und möchte eigentlich
china nicht weiter provozieren also das
wird spannend wie das genau formuliert
sein wird neue bedrohungen also das sind
der gigantische zahlen die in diesem
kontext da gestern gemeldet wurden eine
fast verachtfachung der schnellen
eingreiftruppe auf 300.000 soldatinnen
und soldaten
wie sind diese zahlen einzuordnen das
ist tatsächlich eine gigantische summe
die quasi mit zahlen aus dem kalten
krieg zu vergleichen ist jens
stoltenberg hat eigentlich für die viele
verbündete überraschend gestern diese
zahl genannt die er im oberen bereich
des möglichen angesiedelt war und viele
haben sich auch erstaunt gezeigt dass
hat das zwei tage vor dem nato-gipfel in
die runde in die öffentlichkeit gebracht
hat es geht darum die schnelle
eingreiftruppe der nato die jetzt wir
haben es gehört ungefähr 40.000 männer
und frauen um fast 300.000 sollen es
werden und es geht um die verstärkung
der ostflanke also der ostgrenze der
nato nach russland die baltischen
staaten haben sich schon lange eine
stärkere präsenz der nato in ihren
ländern gewünscht wie das genau aussehen
soll ist noch nicht klar aber es könnte
zum beispiel so aussehen wie die
bundesrepublik ist tun wird die
bundesrepublik stärker die führungs
nation in litauen und hat jetzt
angekündigt dass sie den umfang einer
brigade also ungefähr 1000 bis
5500 soldaten in deutschland
bereit halten wird die dann sehr schnell
nach liter und verlegt werden könnten
wenn das der nötig wäre anderen nationen
könnten das ähnlich anhaben könnten das
ähnlich handhaben aber wie wirklich
300.000 männer und frauen zusammen
kommen sollen und in welchem zeitrahmen
das ist derzeit noch völlig offen
vielleicht wenn wir da weitere details
erfahren in madrid in den nächsten
stunden und tagen ungelöst ist ja eben
auch noch das thema nato erweiterung um
schweden und finnland werden gerade im
beitrag gesehen da blockiert weiter die
türkei sind da fortschritte ist da
vielleicht sogar ein durchbruch zu
erwarten beim gipfel es gibt heute am
späten nachmittag ein erstes direktes
treffen zwischen den türkischen
präsidenten erdogan mit der schwedischen
und finnischen ministerpräsidenten unter
vermittlung von nato-generalsekretär
jens stoltenberg die nato hat im vorfeld
versucht die erwartungen zu dämpfen
das sei ein historischer schritt der
aber eine so große bedeutung dass man
ihn nicht übers knie brechen könne und
dass es vermutlich noch etwas zeit
bräuchte aber es wäre natürlich ein
ersehntes signal der geschlossenheit der
nato wenn es zu einem durchbruch wenn
die türkei ihre blockade gegenüber
dieser mitgliedschaft von schweden und
finnland aufgeben würde aber der
türkische präsident hat sich in den
letzten wochen trotz massiver einwirkung
der alliierten präsident biden hat heute
morgen von hier aus noch mal mit erdogan
telefoniert
trotzdem hat erdogan bis jetzt nicht
eingelenkt es geht um zwei punkte es
geht einmal um die frage was ist
terrorismus da haben die türkei und die
beiden nordischen
aufnahmeländer sehr unterschiedliche
vorstellungen darüber und die schweden
haben versucht einige einige
zugeständnisse zu machen aber das reicht
den türkischen präsidenten offenbar noch
nicht aus und es geht um
waffenlieferungen auch hier hat schweden
signalisiert man könnte ein embargo
gegen die türkei möglicherweise aufheben
aber erdogan spekuliert wohl eher auf
die teilnahme am f 35 programm der
amerikaner dass gestoppt wurde seit er
ein russisches luftabwehrsystem gekauft
hat also sie sehen die lage ist sehr
kompliziert sie hatten sehr viele
faktoren und ob sich das in den nächsten
zwei tagen in madrid lösen lässt ist
mehr als fraglich wir werden sehr
aufmerksam beobachten wir beobachten
derweil auch dass bundeskanzler scheut
sich dem presse statement nährt ein paar
meter hat er noch vor sich gibt uns die
gelegenheit alle noch mal den blick nach
vorne zu weiten wir haben den g20 gipfel
im november auf bali schon angesprochen
wird dann eine ganz andere
zusammensetzung als der gipfel hier in
ellmau mit dabei eben russland und auch
china ist man sich hier in ellmau denn
einig geworden wie man da vorgehen will
wie man vor allem putin gegenüber
auftreten will ich weiß nicht ob es
schon eine endgültige entscheidung gibt
aber auf jeden fall war das hier thema
bei dem treffen der sieben großen
industrienationen und man hat sich
überlegt wie verhalten wir uns denn bei
dem g 20 gipfel bei dem der indonesische
vorsitzende der präsident wladimir putin
ausdrücklich eingeladen hat er hat auch
sehr lenski aus der ukraine eingeladen
aber die frage ist setzen wir uns mit
putin in bali im november an einen tisch
und hier wurde zwar noch nicht
abschließend aber doch die diskussion
geführt
wir können dieses format nicht den
autokratien überlassen wir sollten da
hinfahren wir sollten putin die meinung
sagen aber wir können nicht zulassen
dass sich russland indien china
indonesien zusammen an einen tisch
setzen und die europäer nicht daran
teilnehmen also die vorsichtige annahme
dieses g7 treffens ist dass man nach
bali reisen wird und das dann dass das
dann ein sehr konfliktreiche sign
krawallige treffen auf bali werden wird
dann wollen wir noch ganz kurz nach
moskau schalten auf die gefallen dass
wir dann gleich schon unterbrochen
werden vom bundeskanzler in moskau für
uns unser korrespondent axel sturm axel
die g7 länder haben gestern erklärt er
muss eben gesehen man werde die ukraine
so lange unterstützen wie nötig also
egal wie lange der krieg dauert macht
dieses commitment eindruck auf putin wie
schätzen sie das ein
ich glaube nicht dass das großen
eindruck beim russischen präsidenten
hinterlässt denn letztendlich ist dieses
statement jahr in abgewandelter form in
der vergangenheit immer wieder
artikuliert worden vielleicht kann man
dazu anfügen dass sich der kreml
sprecher presskopf heute geäußert hat
genau zu dieser frage wie lang dieser
konflikt denn wohl noch dauern werde und
er sagte wolodimir selensky könnte den
konflikt heute beenden noch im laufe
dieses tages die voraussetzung dafür
wäre dass er die ukrainische soldaten
dazu auffordert sich zurückzuziehen und
die waffen abzugeben also man geht hier
immer noch davon aus dass man in einer
position der stärke ist wenngleich auch
das ist ja wirklich offenbar diese wie
sie hier heißt militärische
spezialoperation sich deutlich länger
hinzieht als man das möglicherweise hier
von anfang an antizipiert hatte aber man
geht davon aus dass das früher oder
später zu einem großen erfolg wird die
frage was für ein erfolg dass werden
wird was eigentlich die ziele dieser
operation sind die steht ja immer noch
im raum und dies bislang unbeantwortet
vielen dank für diese erste einschätzung
wir werden sehen was der bundeskanzler
vermutlich auch mit blick auf russland
zu sagen hat jetzt in der
pressekonferenz die dann wohl wirklich
in wenigen sekunden beginnen wird da ist
er am pult wir hören war
herzlich begrüßen zur
abschlusspressekonferenz
in ellmau bundeskanzler oder scholz
meine damen und herren auch von mir ein
herzliches willkommen bei intensive und
sehr konstruktive tage liegen nun hinter
uns der g7 gipfel von ellmau war ein
wichtiger gipfel in einer ganz
besonderen zeit
und das treffen hat noch einmal auf
beeindruckende weise
unsere geschlossenheit und unsere
entschlossenheit gezeigt der russischen
aggression entgegen zu treten
125 tage schon für russland kriegen der
ukraine und gegen die ukraine als g7 als
gruppe der wirtschaftlich starken
demokratien verurteilen wir diesen
erbarmungslosen krieg
der raketenangriff gestern auf ein
einkaufszentrum in krementschouk in der
nähe von kiew mit vielen toten und
verletzten ist erneut der beweis dass
putin seine brutale aggression gegenüber
der bevölkerung beibehält
die g7 stehen das wissen sie eng und
unverbrüchlich an der seite der ukraine
wir unterstützen das land bei seiner
verteidigung
und bieten ihnen eine perspektive für
die zukunft an
hier haben wir auch noch einmal
grundsätzlich ja diskutiert was dieser
angriff der am 24 februar begonnen hat
eigentlich bedeutet ich habe das früher
eine zeitenwende genannt nichts ist mehr
so wie es war
uns allen ist klar dass es kein zurück
geben kann und wirkst du derzeit vor
diesen krieg und seine ist auch klar
uns liegt eine zeit der unsicherheit
dies herausfordernd und darum sind
entschlossenheit und geschlossenheit
ebenso wichtig
und umso wichtiger ist es dass wir in
dieser welt enge freunde und verbündete
haben die sieben staaten die hier
zusammen gekommen sind sind solche engen
freunde und verbündete
das habe ich auch ganz konkret gespürt
bei den treffen die hier einmal
stattgefunden haben bei unseren
diskussionen bei unseren
gesprächen bilateral zu zweit und auch
bei den ungezwungenen begegnung die es
hier immer wieder gaben
emma war sehr gute 7 und die staaten die
hier miteinander kooperieren weil wir
die zeit genutzt haben die g7 partner
und die eingeladenen partnerländer
senegal
indonesien
indien südafrika argentinien
haben aus meiner sicht ein neuer konsens
so formuliert für gemeinsames handeln in
unserer welt und für die zukunft auch
das war ganz ganz wichtig dass wir nicht
nur unter uns geblieben sind sondern
eben diese sieben staaten und viele
internationale organisationen als
gesprächspartner hatten und dass wir mit
ihnen gemeinsam darüber diskutieren
konnten was die demokratien auf dieser
welt miteinander bewirken können auf
augenhöhe denn das ist ja ganz ganz
wichtig mit der heutigen abschluss
erklärung der staats und regierungschefs
und mit den separaten erklärung die wir
als g7 mit unseren partnern der elmer
verabschiedet haben demonstrieren wir
eben die große kraft demokratischer
bündnisse
von diesem treffen morgen drei
botschaften aus
erstens die g7 stehen geeint und ihrer
unterstützung für die ukraine zusammen
wir sind uns
einig präsident putin darf diesen krieg
nicht gewinnen
wir werden weiter die wirtschaftlichen
und politischen kosten dieses krieges
für präsident putin und sein regime
hochhalten und in die höhe treiben
dafür ist es wichtig zusammenzustehen
auch auf der langen strecke um die es
hier sicherlich noch gehen wird
und wir werden auch dem russischen
narrativ entschlossen entgegentreten
dass es sich hier eigentlich um einen
konflikt handle wo nur der westen der so
genannte globale westen diesen angriff
verurteilt und ansonsten die welt
zuschaut dass russland da eigentlich
macht nur ist das nicht das hat sich
auch aus unseren diskussionen ergeben
alle wissen dass zum frieden in der welt
die unantastbarkeit von grenzen die
souveränität von staaten das recht von
staaten gehört über die eigene zukunft
zu entscheiden und nicht vom nachbarn
überfallen zu werden
wir haben als g7 auf diesem gipfel auch
viele einzelne beschlüsse gefasst die
dazu beitragen sollen diese hilfe zu
organisieren etwa finanzielle hilfe als
budget hilfe 29 milliarden us-dollar
sind alles zusammen mobilisiert worden
wir werden auch weiter humanitäre
unterstützung geben das ist auch in 22
schon passiert und wird alles zusammen
28 milliarden dollar umfassen und
natürlich gehört für uns alle dazu dass
wir die ukraine auch mit ihren
militärischen
notwendigkeiten unterstützen und waffen
liefern was alle und viele andere
staaten tun
wir haben uns auch schon unterhalten
über den längerfristigen wiederaufbau
dazu gibt es zusätzliches geld das
mobilisiert werden soll aber das
wichtigste ist dass wir uns
zusammenfinden wollen aus der
perspektive der g7 aber auch aus der
perspektive
anderer der europäischen union um über
die frage eines wiederaufbaus zu
diskutieren wir brauchen einen marshall
plan für die ukraine der muss auch gut
geplant und entwickelt werden das haben
uns vorgenommen
die zweite botschaft des gipfels wir
gehen gemeinsam gegen den hunger in der
welt vor und der ist ja eine noch
größere herausforderung geworden durch
den russischen überfall auf die ukraine
das ist ganz krieg der jetzt viele
menschen in dieser welt fürchten lässt
dass sie sich und ihre familien nicht
mehr ernähren können wir haben
gegenwärtig
345 millionen menschen von denen wir
wissen dass sie nicht ausreichend zu
essen haben das sind viermal so viele
wie in deutschland leben
die klimakrise die pandemie und der
krieg russlands gegen die ukraine haben
diese probleme noch mal verschärft und
es ist eine existenz essentielle
bedrohung in vielen ländern afrikas ganz
besonders wir wollen deshalb auch
handeln und haben deshalb ein globales
bündnis für ernährungssicherheit
geschmiedet
es gibt jetzt finanzielle zusagen von
viereinhalb milliarden us dollar auch
deutschland beteiligt sich daran
substanziell
es geht eben um ganz konkrete schritte
und dazu zählt auch dass wir uns
zusammen mit dem generalsekretär der
vereinten nationen darum bemühen das
getreide und die düngemittel die in der
ukraine
nutzbar lagern auch tatsächlich der welt
verfügbar zu machen
klar ist dieser krieg hat auch gezeigt
wie sehr wir abhängig sind von
energieimporten und in diesem fall ganz
besonders von solchen aus russland und
darum ist es wichtig dass wir diese
abhängigkeiten reduzieren wir werden
deshalb auch das haben wir miteinander
beschlossen den weg zum ausbau der
erneuerbaren
energien weiter mit großer intensität
vorantreiben
und deshalb bleibt es auch bei den
beschlüssen die wir gefasst haben was
die finanzierung fossile energieträger
gibt betrifft das soll zu ende gehen
aber wir werden natürlich jetzt in
dieser ganz konkreten situation vielen
ländern helfen wenn sie für ihre
energieversorgung investitionen tätigen
wollen die zum beispiel wasserstoff
ready sind und diese möglichkeiten jetzt
nutzen so weit dass sich im einklang mit
dem 15 grad ziel des pariser abkommens
befindet
steigende energiepreise gefährden die
sicherheit und stabilität in vielen
ländern das wissen wir und das ist auch
etwas das wir bei der diskussion über
die lage der weltwirtschaft sehr
sorgfältig erörtert haben dazu kommt die
große gefahr der preis steigen der
inflation die generell in vielen ländern
jetzt gegenwärtig beobachtet und von
vielen bürgern und bürger mit sorge
betrachtet wird es war deshalb gut dass
wir uns mit diesen fragen auch
auseinandergesetzt haben und das galt
für uns selbst aber es gilt natürlich
auch für die situation in den schwellen-
und entwicklungsländern die noch mehr
herausgefordert sind von dieser
situation und weniger möglichkeiten
haben mit solchen großen
herausforderungen umzugehen
preissteigerung inflation können
wirtschaftliche stabilität und das
vertrauen in politik untergraben und
deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir
gemeinsam handeln
die dritte botschaft des g 7 gipfel wir
werden die langfristigen aufgaben nicht
aus dem blick verlieren
wir wollen ein fortschritt für eine
gerechte welt und dieser globalen
verantwortung auch gerecht werden
das gilt zum beispiel für den
klimaschutz wir haben uns deshalb hier
unterhalten über die frage eines klima
clubs den ich schon lange vorgeschlagen
habe und ich freue mich deshalb dass wir
uns hier in emma darauf verständigt
haben einen solchen klima club nun bis
ende dieses jahres zu gründen wir haben
das fundament dafür gelegt die tragenden
säulen definiert und die nächsten
schritte vereinbart denn wir sind uns
einig wir brauchen mehr ehrgeiz mehr
ambitionen um unsere klimaziele zu
erreichen mit dem klima club tragen wir
dazu bei dass wir diese verpflichtungen
auch einhalten können und wir wollen
dabei auch erreichen dass wir wenn wir
unsere nationalen strategien
entwickeln um co2 neutrale industrien zu
etablieren und sie durchzusetzen dass
wir dann nicht gegeneinander arbeiten
und uns voneinander abschotten sondern
dass wir zusammenarbeiten
genau das ist das was ein solcher
offener klima club ermöglichen soll er
soll erreichen dass wir unsere
wettbewerbsfähigkeit erhalten und dass
der klimaschutz ein wettbewerbsvorteil
wird und kein nachteil ist
das gilt natürlich ganz besonders für
die energiewende die wir nur hinbekommen
können wenn auch die schwellen und
entwicklungsländer dabei sein können und
deshalb wollen wir auch die grundlagen
dafür legen dass diese länder das auch
tatsächlich können wir haben eine
energiewende partnerschaft mit afrika
entwickelt und haben jetzt für unseren
beitrag von 700 millionen euro ein café
förderkredit von 300 millionen euro
schon auf den weg gebracht der
südafrikanische präsident hat sich über
diese konkretisierung unserer
gemeinsamen vereinbarung gefreut und wir
werden auch weitere solche
partnerschaften staaten mit indien
indonesien sehen egal und vietnam sind
die nächsten geplant es geht eben darum
dass wir zusammenarbeiten
nochmal was uns vereint
ist das was unsere gemeinsamen werte
ausmacht demokratie menschenrechte
frieden und freiheit das verbindet uns
eben miteinander aber auch mit den
partnerländern mit denen wir gesprochen
haben und denen die hier eingeladen habe
wie schon erwähnt sehen egal indonesien
südafrika argentinien und indien es sind
demokratische stimmen des globalen
südens und sie sind die richtigen
partner mit denen wir hier miteinander
über die probleme unserer gemeinsamen
welt gesprochen haben
wir werden es eben auch nur zusammen
hinbekommen was wir uns vorgenommen
haben fortschritt für eine gerechte welt
und deshalb bleibt es dabei dass wir uns
auch auf solche weise unterhalten müssen
wir das hier in ellmau der fall gewesen
ist ich glaube dass diese gipfeltreffen
unverändert von größter größter
bedeutung sind man hat mich viel von
treffen wo sich politiker begegnen in
den letzten jahren ja oft auch noch am
video stream und dann statements ablesen
es muss schon direkte gespräche geben
dass man aufeinander eingeht dass man
die lateral einmal weiter erörtert dass
man gesprächsfäden dem angeknüpft hat
einen halben tag später einen tag später
wieder aufgreifen kann und das ist hier
gelungen insofern hat es sich wirklich
ausgezahlt dass wir hier miteinander
geredet haben es ist großes vertrauen
untereinander gestanden entstanden und
es wird uns für die nächste zeit sehr
helfen bedanken möchte ich mich bei den
beschäftigten auf schloss elmau die hier
unglaublich zu dem erfolg dieses
gipfeltreffens beigetragen haben mit
ihrer gastfreundschaft das war sehr sehr
gut und sehr schön das zu erleben man
danke den polizisten und
sicherheitskräften die hier gearbeitet
haben die tag und nacht dafür gesorgt
haben dass die sicherheit auch
gewährleistet dass die bundespolizei die
bayerische polizei feuerwehr technisches
hilfswerk viele viele flirten und
natürlich bedanke ich mich auch bei den
bürgern und bürger nennt gründen und
garmisch partenkirchen so antreffen es
für die bürgerinnen bürger dieser orte
eben auch mit belastungen verbunden
gewesen und deshalb danke danke für das
verständnis für die unterstützung und
sicherlich an der einen oder anderen
stelle auch für den langmut ich bedanke
mich ganz sicher auch im namen aller
delegation die hier gewesen sind sie
waren gerne hier zu gast
die deutsche b 7 präsidentschaft das ist
mir wichtig ist noch nicht zu ende sie
geht noch das ganze jahr und da dieses
wie ich eingangs gesagt habe ein ganz
besonderes jahr ist wird es sicherlich
so sein dass wir auch noch viel
miteinander zu reden und zu handeln
haben das wird jetzt aber viel besser
funktionieren weil wir unsere zeit hier
so gut genutzt haben und es ist auch ein
signal der klarheit und stärke ein
solches signal der cloud und stärke ist
auch gerade wichtig im vorfeld zu dem
nato gipfel in madrid zu dem ich heute
noch aufbrechen werde und in dem es auch
darum geht dass in diesem fall die
transatlantische partnerschaft
zeigt wozu wir in der lage sind und dass
wir die verteidigung unserer länder und
unserer demokratie
gemeinsam organisieren können
als erstes fragestellung hat es michael
fischer ich würde bitten also ein
bisschen unübersichtlich ist die hand zu
heben dann kommt
derjenige der sprechen will erst mal
ankommen das mikro hin ich habe schon
fünf frage meldung dann komme ich so
langsam ich kann nicht versprechen wir
haben etwa einer dreiviertelstunde ob
alle dran kommen aber michael fischer
wird sicherlich mit einer frage anfangen
vielen dank herr bundeskanzler es war in
den letzten tagen
auffällig dass die wichtigen ergebnisse
dieses gipfels gibt es von
amerikanischer seite kommuniziert worden
sind da würde ich gerne wissen warum sie
sich da so viel zurückhaltung selbst
auferlegt haben und den amerikanern den
vortritt gelassen haben und wie würden
sie ihre rolle in den beratungen selbst
beschreiben sind sie da er als moderator
aufgetreten oder sind sie mit dem
anspruch da reingegangen eine
führungsrolle einzunehmen und voran zu
marschieren danke für die sehr netten
fragen also zunächst mal habe ich das
gefühl dass wir gemeinsame ergebnis
erzielt haben sie auch gemeinsam
kommuniziert haben mich teile also diese
beobachtung nicht und ansonsten war das
hier wirklich eine sehr gute diskussion
die trotzdem stringent gebliebenes mit
ergebnissen die wir vorbereitet und
sorgfältig miteinander erarbeitet haben
und ich bin sehr froh dass ich dazu
einen wichtigen beitrag leisten konnte
den g7 präsidentschaften beschränken
sich ja nicht auf sitzungsleitung da
geht es ja um viel viel mehr
als nächstes daniela vater ist hier
vorne
herr scholz ich würde ganze ukraine
fragen und zwar bis sich gerne ob sie
hier beide 7 irgendwelche neuen ideen
entwickelt haben wie man diese diesen
krieg eindämmen kann und ob sie auch
über preis caps gesprochen haben und
wieder die entwicklung sein wird
die ukraine ich hab eben schon darüber
gesprochen hat eine
große zeit unserer beratung beansprucht
richtigerweise denn dieser krieg ist ja
eine enorme herausforderung für die
friedensordnung in europa und in der
welt etwas das uns wichtig ist zu sagen
das ist nicht nur ein krieg in europa
mit dem bruch der regeln die wir
miteinander gefunden haben in den
letzten jahren ist eine bedrohung für
die frieden und für frieden und
sicherheit in der ganzen welt verbunden
und deshalb haben wir
viele dinge miteinander noch einmal
verstärkt und uns untergehakt wenn es um
die finanzielle unterstützung geht wenn
es um humanitäre unterstützung geht wenn
es um die frage der sanktionspolitik
hingeht die wir mit daran da haben aber
natürlich auch wenn es darum geht
waffenlieferungen zu ermöglichen mit
denen die ukraine in die lage versetzt
sich zu verteidigen die diskussion waren
sehr im einzel und sehr konkret und
haben natürlich auch dazu beigetragen
dass wir noch mal sicher alle sagen
können wir handeln nicht nur gemeinsam
sondern auch auf die gleiche art und
weise und das passt zusammen was wir da
miteinander machen und das glaube ich
ist dann auch das was uns die kraft für
die zukunft gibt gegenwärtig muss man
konstatieren dass putin seinen brutalen
krieg fortsetzt gerade deshalb ist es so
wichtig dass wir hier auch nochmal
bekundet haben dass unsere hilfe weiter
groß sein wird dass wir sie auch weiter
steigern werden und dass wir sie so
lange fortsetzen werden wie das
notwendig ist
nächstes ralph bollmann fas mit die hier
herr scholz wir haben die große
einmütigkeit mit den ländern des
globalen südens
betont in fragen russland ukraine nun
gibt es ja was die sanktionspolitik und
das unterlaufen von sanktionen betrifft
da doch große differenzen haben sie das
gefühl dass sie für ihre position für
die position der g7 da mehr verständnis
gewonnen haben und dass sich da auch
etwas bewegen könnte dankeschön
wir haben die fragen natürlich
diskutiert und sehr klar
formuliert es ist der russische
angriffskrieg der die
dramatischen auswirkungen auf die
weltwirtschaft hat die wir heute schon
sehen ich habe über den hunger
gesprochen das ist ein großes problem
ich habe steigende preise gerade auch
für energie gesprochen das ist ein
großes problem und deshalb haben wir
unseren gesprächspartnern sehr genau
versichert dass wir uns
soldatisch unterhaken werden dass wir
helfen werden mit dieser herausforderung
umzugehen und dass der beste weg diese
herausforderungen zu lösen natürlich
wäre das russland sahen angriffskrieg
beendet und seine truppen wieder
zurückzieht und das war ein thema über
das wir diskutiert haben klar ist dass
in den ländern des globalen südens
darüber auch unterschiedliche ansichten
existieren das kann man ja schon ein
abstimmungsverhalten verschiedener
länder bei der generalversammlung der
vereinten nationen sehen aber das ist
schon mein sicherer eindruck niemand hat
zweifel daran was die ursache für diesen
konflikt ist nehme man mit dem wir
gesprochen haben es ist ein russischer
angriff auf einen nachbarn der diesen
angriff nicht provoziert hat und der das
opfer eine aggression ist ja und dann
dieser stelle wollen wir uns ausklinken
und das ganze einmal einordnen den
beginn macht wieder theo koll unser
leiter des zdf-hauptstadtstudios theo
kann es hat erwartungsgemäß viele themen
nur noch einmal behandelt in seinem
statement bevor er ins detail gehen gibt
es ein zwei haupt erkenntnisse die sich
aus diesem statement aus dieser
pressekonferenz mit nehmen lassen also
ich fand es interessant wie am anfang
und am ende auch im grunde das große
bild gezeichnet hat
und auch die g7 noch mal gelobt hat als
forum er hat ja gesagt ich zitiere mal
nichts ist mehr so wie es war wir leben
in einer zeit der großen unsicherheit
und umso wichtiger ist es in einer
solchen zeit enge freunde und verbündete
zu haben und das seien die g7 dieses
format habe sich sehr gelohnt das hörte
man auch im vorfeld in den vergangenen
tagen schon dass diese entspannte
atmosphäre sehr dazu beigetragen hat die
abgeschiedenheit in gewisser weise auch
aber dass man eben wieder miteinander
reden konnte und nicht über
videokonferenzen also das fand ich
interessant dass er im grunde das
eingebettet hat in das große
internationale
geschehen und dann hat er ja selber die
drei kernbotschaften zusammengefasst
genau nun endet damit die rolle als
gastgeber für olaf scholz es ging ja
viel um nähe bei diesem gipfel damit hat
noch einmal angesprochen wortwörtliche
auch im akkord zum beispiel hat einmal
den indischen premier moody kaum mehr
losgelassen auch joe biden hat viele
getätschelt boris johnson hat sich oft
in den mittelpunkt gedrängt wie immer
möchte man fast sagen scholz ist da eher
kühler hanseat hat ihm diese
gastgeberrolle gelegen was war ihr
eindruck also diese form von
symbolpolitik auch vermittelt über
gestik die ist natürlich nicht stolz
zeigen es ist nicht seine kernkompetenz
er hat das eigentlich nicht sehr gerne
hält distanz ich habe makro ja sehr
lange aus der nähe erlebte hat
donald trump umworben wie kaum ein
zweiter er hat ihn er hat eine eigene
hat ihn eingeladen zur parade im sommer
in paris hat ihn in einen drei sterne
restaurant seiner wahl eingeladen er hat
auch putin umworben hat ihn in die
sommerresidenz eingeladen und immer auch
diese sehr enge körperlichkeit aber
gebracht um ehrlich zu sein hat es am
ende dann doch nichts es gilt die alte
regel in der internationalen politik es
sind die interessen der staaten die am
ende wirklich den ausschlag geben
insofern ist das was man jetzt bei olaf
scholz immer wieder natürlich merkt dass
er eher scheu ist auch im umgang mit
menschen das eher zurückhaltende ist am
ende glaube ich wird das in der politik
keinen großen unterschied machen die
globale realpolitik schauen wir zum
abschluss noch kurz auf die
innenpolitische lage in der
vergangenheit war es ja oft so dass
solche gipfel die position der
regierungschefs gestärkt haben wenn sie
gastgeber waren wird es auch jetzt für
urlaubsgeld man musste ja zurückliegend
einiges an kritik einstecken auch
innerhalb seiner ampel koalition was ist
da ihre einschätzung ich glaube davon
kann man ausgehen also erst als
gastgeber hat keine fehler gemacht er
war hier auf der großen weltbühne er hat
die welt empfangen als moderator im
grunde zurückhaltend aber er hat die
richtigen akzente gesetzt und er hat im
grunde nach vorne geschaut indem er
diese fünf strategischen länder
eingeladen hat die für die zukunft sehr
wichtig sind wenn man darf nicht
vergessen diese g7 das ist ein alter
klub das ist ein club der eigentlich die
70er und 80er jahre spiegelt die
weltwirtschaft hat sich längst verändert
die tektonischen platten die bedeutung
der länder haben sich verschoben es gibt
viel wichtigere länder und insofern ist
es wichtig dass er diese initiative
ergriffen hat die nach vorne geht und
insofern glaube ich dass er hier
durchaus auch wichtige akzente gesetzt
hat einordnung des leiters unseres
zdf-hauptstadtstudios theo koll vielen
dank
ja und fester bestandteil wenn auch
nicht offizieller bestandteil solcher
gipfel sind ja stets proteste und
demonstrationen
die sind dieses jahr vielfach deutlich
kleiner ausgefallen als in der
vergangenheit auch als hier im vorfeld
erwartet worden war von vielen die
polizeipräsenz die war enorm claudia
vogel man schaut nun in ihrer bilanz
darauf
es werden immer weniger im camp der
gipfelgegner viele haben ihre zelte
schon abgebaut statt der erwarteten 700
demonstranten sollen hier nur 400
campiert haben momo und victor haben bis
zuletzt aus gehabt sie haben redebedarf
was nicht so gut gelaufen ist und warum
wir jetzt auch gerade hier stehen ist
dass wir in unserer versammlungsfreiheit
mit dieser karawane extrem eingeschränkt
werden und zwar schon seit tagen und
immer wieder auch
merken wir dass die polizei zu unseren
veranstaltungen kommt jetzt nicht nur
hier sondern zum beispiel auch in
münchen in den vergangenen tagen ist es
zufall dass just zu diesem zeitpunkt ein
polizeihubschrauber über dem kreis fakt
ist die polizei ist mit 18.000 beamten
rund um den g 7 gipfel im einsatz sie
ist präsent tag und nacht am tagungsort
bei jeder demo und darüber hinaus
diese demonstranten werden nicht nur
aufmerksam beobachtet sondern auch
begleitet in diesem bus etwa der 50
vorher registrierte teilnehmer in die
nähe des tagungsortes bringt am ende
sind mehr polizisten als demonstranten
vor ort
dann halte ich dieses polizeiaufgebot
für vollkommen übertrieben das ist ja
ein betreuungsschlüssel den würde ich
mir in der schule in der ich arbeite mal
wünschen dann könnten wir kindern gute
dinge beibringen
der gegner hat mehr recht eingeklagt in
hör- und sichtweite gesehen und gehört
zu werden
am ziel wird es turbulent einige gipfel
gegner sind nicht da wo sie sein sollten
sie blockieren die straßen werden
weggetragen auch mit einem sternmarsch
hatten die gegner angekündigt zum
tagungsort zu gelangen der fußmarsch
findet nicht viele anhänger ist es das
heiße wetter oder die wegstrecke von
rund 20 kilometern nur 100 menschen
schließen sich der demo wanderung an und
nehmen den aufstieg in kauf
wenn wir mal anliegen wichtiges million
für mehr klimagerechtigkeit zu
protestieren und die wirklich
interessieren will die sitze nun mal
anderen seite des berges parallel gibt
es auch eine fahrer dem os kommen
lediglich drei radfahrer einer davon ein
polizist
die innenstadt von garmisch
partenkirchen ist auch am dritten und
letzten gipfeltag nichts her belebt die
meisten geschäfte haben zu die optikerin
vorsitzenden der garmischer
einzelhändler michael hebel öffnet am
morgen ihr geschäft obwohl kein großer
umsatz zu erwarten ist einen dritten
g7-gipfel wünscht sie sich nicht ja
woanders
[Gelächter]
ich bin mal gespannt wie sich die
bundesregierung dann hilfe entscheidet
auch der landrat anton speer ist pro
wendige sieben teilnehmer und die
karawane der gipfelgegner am dritten und
letzten tag endlich wieder aus dem tal
ziehen dann sagt er uns wird es für ihn
richtig gemütlich hoffen wir dass dies
alles gut geht dass er keine
zwischenfälle gibt und dann heute abend
um 4.20 uhr wenn ihr endlich zur ruhe
kommen dann mache ich eine halbe bier
auf und genieße ich natürlich volle züge
der zweite g7-gipfel auf schloss elmau
die zu ende ob die anliegen der
demonstranten gehör gefunden haben
bleibt bis zur stunde offen ja dann
sagen wir schon mal prost wir haben's
gesehen viele der proteste die drehen
sich um das thema klima krise dazu nun
bei uns christian decker aus unserer
zdf-redaktion umwelt christian es gab ja
sehr viel bekenntnis zum kampf gegen die
klimakrise kritiker sagen das habe
keinen substanziellen schritt nach vorne
gegeben im gegenteil sogar einen kleinen
rückschritt dadurch dass nun wieder
investitionen in fossile energien
möglich sein stichwort lng ist dieser
vorwurf berechtigt ja und nein also da
muss man genau gucken was in diesem
komitee drinsteht was vereinbart wurde
es ist so dass die industriestaaten bei
der letzten un klimakonferenz in glasgow
versprochen hatten solche subventionen
und investitionen in fossile energien im
ausland einzustellen jetzt ist die
energie sicherheit bedroht und jetzt
braucht man eben wieder zumindest
kurzfristig diese fossilen energien und
möchte dort investieren aus klima sicht
ist da ganz entscheidend ob das
investitionen sind die zu einem
langfristigen effekt führen also sprich
das fossile energien hier langfristig
genutzt werden oder ob es ebenso ist
dass das nur um ein zwei drei jahre geht
um dann nur einen kurzfristigen effekt
was die fossilen energien ansonsten an
geht was die elektrik elektrik angeht
wird das elektrische netz angeht was die
kohle angeht da muss man gucken was hier
beschlossen wurde bei g 7 und das kannst
du stolz hat da nichts konkretes
zugesagt
ist auch der so genannte klima club
angelegt ist stichwort dass wir diese
sendungen schon mehrfach gehört haben
diese idee stammt noch aus olaf scholz
zeit als finanzminister wenn du uns noch
mal kurz erklären kannst was ist kern
der idee und wieweit hat er die hier
vorantreiben können die kernidee das
klima clubs ist schneller voranzugehen
zum beispiel beim ausbau der neue
erneuerbare energien bei technologien
die das klima schonen aber auch bei der
vermeidung von emissionen bei der
reduktion der co2 emissionen
ein problem ist dass bisher länder die
besonders viel für das klima tun die
befürchtung haben dass sie im
internationalen wettbewerb im globalen
wirtschaftlichen handelns schlechter
dastehen als länder die sich da
zurückhaltend ein konkretes beispiel bei
der stahlproduktion die sehr co2
intensiv ist wenn man da einen co2 preis
erhebt in europa zum beispiel ist dieser
staat am ende möglicherweise teurer als
der stahl der in china produziert wird
und da will dieser klima club gemeinsame
standards schaffen um sozusagen eine
vergleichbarkeit auf einer
wirtschaftlichen ebene eine
vergleichbarkeit der produkte zu
schaffen bundeskanzler scholz hat jetzt
angekündigt bis zum ende des jahres
einen solchen club gründen zu wollen und
hier auch konkrete vorlagen zu machen
wie das vonstatten gehen soll da muss
man aber sehen dass eben nicht nur die
starken g7-staaten die starken
industriestaaten am ende clubmitglieder
sind sondern dass es eben auch hier um
schwellenländer geht um ärmere länder um
länder wie indien china indonesien die
eben nach wie vor sehr stark in den
fossilen energien
spielen also auch das ein thema das uns
noch langfristig begleiten wird
christian decker aus der umwelt
redaktion vielen dank
ja und das war unser heute spezial am
mittag ein weiteres gibt es heute abend
und zwar mit einem interview mit
bundeskanzler olaf scholz matthias
fornoff begrüßt sie dazu gleich nach den
heute -nachrichten gegen 19 uhr 20 ihnen
in vielen dank für ihr interesse und
einen schönen tag wie die grüße aus
garmisch
[Musik]